in this video i'm going to show you how
i recommend learning
r i think this is going to work for you
no matter what background you're coming
from
and better yet it's not going to cost
you a dime make sure you watch until the
very end though because there is more
than one resource that i recommend using
[Music]
so the r programming language has had a
fairly significant surge in its use
throughout the data science community
during the last year
probably in great part due to the
pandemic and associated research
and i certainly don't see that changing
anytime soon
and so i recommend for people trying to
break into the data science field
pick one of r or python learn it and get
really good at it
if r is the language that you pick it
begs a fairly natural follow-up question
which is
how exactly do you go about learning it
well i'm going to give you a
recommendation for that today
besides of course my own art tutorials
i'll have a link to those in the
description
before i do that though take a moment to
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already
hit the bell so you never miss an update
and then tap the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and then if you guys want to support my
channel i will have links in the
description to my paypal account and to
my crypto wallet addresses
all right so before we get into exactly
how to learn r
i'm going to go over what actually
learning the language is going to look
like and then also what not to do
so ideally if you've mastered the r
programming language
you're going to be comfortable with
different stages of the data science
pipeline
and what i mean by that is suppose
you're starting with some
really messy data you're able to pick it
up
clean it transform it into whatever type
of format that's required
you're comfortable with things like
loops and functions and simple
simulations
and you can also create basic output
like visualizations
reports and models that also means that
when a project or task
comes around that you just feel
confident you're able to put different
things that you know together and get
creative
what you don't want to have happen is
you know a whole bunch of
theory like you know all the different
data types and
object types and things like that but
you're not able to convert that into any
kind of
action because you just haven't put it
into practice yet
so you need to practice as you go and
after you've learned all the
fundamentals
because if you're just reading along and
just looking at other people's code
casually
you're just not gonna get good at it i'm
a huge fan
of starting off by learning things like
how to clean a dataset or
create visualizations because that way
you're starting off by doing something
practical
you're less likely to get bored and give
up but don't just learn
only one narrow sliver of r like it's
not enough just to know how to create
visualizations or create models
learn how to do something go back and
learn the fundamentals
and then learn how to do other things
again there's many different parts of
data science
from cleaning your data creating
visualizations
models reports whatever your final
output is
just make sure you know different parts
of that process
so now i'm going to tell you what my
all-time favorite resource for beginners
to learn r
is and it's the book r for data science
by hadley wickham
hedley wickham is actually the chief
scientist over at r studio
and he's been the primary creator of a
unified framework of packages called the
tidy verse
the tidy verse is basically a set of
packages that share a common framework
syntax design etc etc
each package in the tidy verse serves a
different purpose
whether that's ggplot2 for data
visualization
the plyar for data manipulation and
these packages and the functions in them
are meant to flow seamlessly from one to
another
and this book is freely available online
now if you do want a hard copy of it
i'll have an
amazon link in the description but
there's really no reason to do that
unless you absolutely want a hard copy
the digital copy is also in the
description obviously
what i love about this book so much is
that it walks you through the various
tiny verse packages
but like i mentioned you start off by
doing things rather than learning a
whole bunch of theory
like in the first 10 minutes of the book
you're going to learn how to create
visualizations using the
very popular ggplot2 package
so immediately after picking up the book
you're learning how to create things
that are tangible and useful
in fact let's go ahead and take a look
at the organization and the structure of
this book
so you see okay there's a couple
introductory chapters no big deal but
then chapter 3
steps you through the grammar of
graphics framework
you start learning gg plot 2 and
creating all these nice graphics
and it's just full of these chunks of
code that if you want
you can copy into your own script or
notebook
and just have as an easily accessible
resource
anytime next chapter keeps going into
coding basics
then the next chapter after after that
is all about data transformation with
the deplier package
then there are all these other packages
after that which will show you how to do
things like work with tables
import data get it into the specific
tidy format
join tables together deal with weird
data types like strings
factors and date times lots of good
stuff
but then by the end you're learning
things like functions and iterations
you know how to build models and you can
use the wonderful r markdown
framework for building reports where
you've got your code and your commentary
and your output
all in one location now is this a
perfect book
no it's not because frankly no resource
on the planet is perfect
in particular it doesn't cover much in
the way of machine learning
or building web apps using the very
popular shiny package
but the book is comprehensive in the
sense that it's going to get you
acquainted with the fundamentals
but you're going to be able to take any
type of dirty data set
work with it manipulate it and get it
into a nice format so that you can do
other things with it and at the end of
the day that's something we all need to
be able to do
so let's say you go through that whole
book and assuming you take
one hour per chapter or so which i think
is really on the high end
considering some chapters in there are
only about one page long
that's going to take you about 30 hours
total
in my opinion that's really not that bad
after that you hopefully have a side
script or notebook that you've created
based on the stuff you've gone through
from the book where it's full of
examples that are reusable
maybe you've changed some little things
here and there just to get a feel for
how all the code works
but you do still need some practice as
well as to get a feel for how various
different people
write code and that's going to bring us
to one of the other best resources on
the planet
and that's kaggle so once you go over to
kaggle
you can click on notebooks then you
select r
to filter down to only r based notebooks
and you can find plenty of public
notebooks where other people have worked
through
problems you can literally pick anything
here skim through one or two of these a
week or something
and you're going to learn tons just from
doing that
ultimately you do need to write your own
code and try some real problems
well if you try any of these challenges
you are going to get some hands-on
experience
working with data and writing your own
original code
now you don't have to submit anything
per se and this is
not a substitute for the experience that
you're gonna get in the real world
but it's much much better than nothing
and it will give you something that you
can put on a portfolio or a resume on
top of that
so there you go that's two incredible
ways to learn
r that will be effective i think no
matter where you're coming from
and that won't cost you anything now
there are some other honorable mentions
that i'll point out
one of them is the swirl package in r
this is just a package that you can
install
and load and it comes with various
different tutorials you can walk through
directly in our studio as well as some
exercises in each one that you can try
i'm also a big fan of the code academy
website in general
it's also got a pretty nice structure to
it for r
so it can be a pretty good supplemental
resource
that also won't cost you anything but
then if you guys do want to go the
coursera route just for the
certification aspect
by all means go for it but at the end of
the day
there are a lot of people out there who
want to shill their courses
but i think there's just so much out
there there's just no reason to pay a
dime out of pocket to learn r
learning a programming language should
not be frustrating or expensive
it should be pretty straightforward and
maybe even a little
fun and i think with the resources that
i've laid out here
while they're not perfect they are going
to give you a pretty solid overview of
the different aspects of a data science
process
and make you confident in the things
that you've learned as well as give you
a little bit of practice
so that you don't learn something and
then immediately forget it
so i'll leave it there thanks for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
please consider sharing it tap the like
button
and then leave me a comment down below
and let me know how you personally
learned
r do you recommend the way that you
chose to learn r
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data